ici l'histoire est une fierté et c'est
une promesse d'avenir ici c'est l'europe
et la france
ici plus qu'ailleurs nous savons qu'il
faut être fier de son identité et de son
histoire parce que ses racines sont la
meilleure promesse de l'avenir alors ici
mes amis alors que nous sommes sur la
fin de campagne
je veux vous le dire nous avons besoin
de vous françois xavier a besoin de vous
il y a un espoir qui a commencé à
renaître pour notre famille politique
dans cette campagne demain ce sera une
force que personne n'arrêtera ce que
nous vous proposons c'est le plus beau
des combats
je ne connais pas de plus noble aux
politiques profondes et l'europe et
rétablir la france et l'europe
et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]